welcome to CBS this morning it's a big
day in Washington you could call it an
historic day for the nation with the
first public hearings on the potential
impeachment of the President of the
United States mr. Trump set to begin in
just a few hours it's a rare moment when
Congress takes on one of the most
serious responsibilities under the
Constitution this morning in this
hearing room the House Intelligence
Committee will address the question at
hand did President Trump withhold
military age of pressure Ukraine to
investigate Democrats including former
Vice President Joe Biden members will
question Bill Taylor the top US diplomat
in Ukraine and Deputy Assistant
Secretary of State George Kent
both men are career foreign service
officials who have served presidents of
both parties for more than half a
century combined President Trump has
repeatedly denounced the impeachment
inquiry and we expect to hear from him
later Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill in
the room where this morning's hearing
will take place Nancy what can we expect
well this is one of the largest hearing
rooms at the Capitol Anthony de the two
witnesses will be questioned by the
members of the House Intelligence
Committee for at least four hours both
sides held practice sessions last night
for what will be the first impeachment
hearing in more than two decades judge
for yourself what you think these people
are saying Democrats and Republicans
both claim the public will be swayed
once it hears the evidence there was no
quick phone call
Democratic aides say George Kent and
Bill Taylor were chosen to testify first
because they watched this pressure
campaign unfold from their posts in
Ukraine and DC the two have described US
policy in Ukraine as highly irregular
alarming and a crisis that threatened to
consume the u.s. Ukraine relationship
Taylor said the Ukrainians were just
desperate when they learned that
millions in aid had been withheld but
the President Trump insisted that the
Ukrainian president go to a microphone
and say he is opening investigations of
former Vice President Joe Biden I don't
think there's anyone better than Bill
Taylor
and a bird's-eye view of a scheme to
extort Ukraine but Republicans will
argue today that Taylor and Kent got
some of their information
secondhand bill Taylor never never
talked with never talked with the
president there was all kinds of
important meetings that he wasn't
present if Democrats decide to go
through with impeachment the House
Judiciary Committee would have to write
and approve articles of impeachment that
would then go to the full house for a
vote before your meeting in an interview
with NPR House Intelligence Chairman
Adam Schiff hinted at the articles of
impeachment to come saying the
conditioning of US military aid on
private political help could be seen as
a bribe bribe only requires that you're
soliciting something of value it doesn't
have to be cash and clearly this was
something of great value to the
president Washington State Democrat
Denny heck is one of 22 members who will
be asking the questions today they say
that there's not enough evidence that
the President himself withheld this aid
in order to pressure Ukraine there's
more evidence to prove that the
president attempted to bribe or extort
Ukraine with the threat of withholding
vital military assistance then there is
evidence to support the idea that the
Sun will come up in the East tomorrow
and there are many more public hearings
to come Democrats just announced last
night that eight more people will
testify next week including lieutenant
colonel alex Vinland and ambassador to
the EU Gordon Sandlin Republicans had
requested nine of their own witnesses
and Democrats are going to allow three
of them to testify as well Toni first
public impeachment hearings in two
decades and historic day indeed Nancy
thank you very much